russian president vladimir putin is
hosting his turkish
counterpart richard tayyip erdogan for
talks now topping their agenda is the
future of syria's kurdish controlled
areas
kurdish militias control much of
northern syria that after
pushing out so-called islamic state
is has lost almost all of its territory
in syria and that's led
president trump to withdraw the 2000 or
so
american troops supporting the kurds
erdogan
regards the kurdish militias as
terrorists and he sees their presence
along
turkey's border at southern border there
as a threat
to national security in a phone call
with president trump he proposed
a turkish-controlled safe zone along the
border
now turkey is also seeking control of
manbij that
city of course was captured by the kurds
from is back in 2016.
with the u.s now poised to withdraw the
kurds are trying to avoid
a full-on turkish military assault from
troops
that are poised at that border region
they've turned
to russia for diplomatic help now the
kurds have long dreamed of
one day establishing an autonomous
region
in northern syria but strategically the
position of kurdish forces has become
precarious in the wake of washington's
planned withdrawal
this was the scene in northeast syria
two days ago
when a convoy of u.s and kurdish-led
troops was bombed in an attack
claimed by islamic state
and exactly one week ago in kurdish held
manbij
near the turkish border
another apparent is attack that killed
four americans
despite the ongoing fighting washington
remains committed to withdrawing its
troops
meaning syria's kurds are about to lose
a powerful ally
then there's the issue of a safe zone
along the border with turkey
a u.s proposal
but who should create it and who should
police it
for russia which backed syria's
government forces the answer is clear
we we are convinced that the best and
only solution
is the transfer of these territories to
the control of the syrian government
and of syrian security forces and
administrative functions
structure but turkey equally wants
control of this buffer zone
to protect against what it sees as the
kurdish threat
our proposal for a safe zone comes with
the goal of keeping terrorists
and terror organizations away from our
border
ankara insists syrian kurdish fighters
are linked to the kurdish rebel group
the pkk
widely branded a terrorist organization
it doesn't want syrian kurdish militia
gaining power on its borders
fearing that might encourage the kurdish
insurgency inside turkey
this time last year turkey launched its
military operation
on the former kurdish enclave of afrin
in northern syria
kurds marked the anniversary with
protests
they have reason to fear that turkey
will strike again
that's why kurdish fighters are now
reaching out to syrian government troops
for protection so what's in the store
for northern syria for more on that we
have dw's emily sherwin in moscow where
those talks are taking place today and
in istanbul we have dw's yulia hahn good
morning to both of you
emily first to you the planned u.s
withdrawal from syria would leave a
power vacuum
in the area how does the kremlin want to
fill it
well absolutely this uh announcement of
the us withdrawal
would have been uh music to russia's
ears um
if the u.s withdraws that will basically
leave russia in control of the skies and
they'll be the only
non-regional power with a stake in
syria's future
and they've also been saying for a long
time that the u.s is basically as they
see it an occupying force
in syria because their presence there
has not been agreed with
the syrian government and that's a hint
basically at what putin wants for
syria's future
he absolutely wants to consolidate the
syrian government's
control over the country and he wants to
play a big role in the future in the
peace process
um in syria and um have a stake in the
future of that country which of course
would give russia
a foothold in syria in the middle east
including militarily
yulia president erdogan wants a safe
zone
in northern syria he has a different
view there
what does he have in mind
president erdogan established turkey as
one of the key players
in the syrian conflict especially last
year alongside
russia iran and the u.s and now he also
wants to secure his
interests before the americans pull out
their troops from syria he also wants to
make sure
he has a say he wants to consolidate
even extend
his influence over there and his main
objective that's something we heard
already
is to push back the kurdish ypg fighters
uh these fighters are allied with the
americans they've helped them
in their fight against islamic state
terrorists but for
president aaron these kurdish fighters
too are terrorists and he wants them
uh and i quote him here to wipe them off
the map and this will be his message in
moscow today he'll also present his
plans
for a so-called safe zone he has been
talking about this with washington
already the details are not quite clear
yet
but the turks wanted to be about 32
kilometers deep extending into syrian
territory from the turkish border
free of any ypg fighters and controlled
by turkey and now
it will be of course interesting to see
what president putin has to say about
that
it will indeed emily could turkey's
proposed safe zone
32 kilometers deep into syria fit in
with russia's strategic interests
well that safe zone is certainly more of
a turkish plan
and russia knows that uh the assad
regime has said that it is categorically
against
that area that buffer zone or safe zone
being controlled
by turkish troops now there may be some
sort of a compromise
on the table today of vladimir putin has
said before that perhaps that buffer
zone that safe zone
could be controlled by syrian government
troops and this month
the russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov also reiterated against
that these territories um could be
under syrian control that in fact that
is the only option and he also welcomed
the fact that the syrian government
had held talks with kurdish
representatives so that could
perhaps be um a a compromise on the line
on the table today okay possible
compromise out there yulia for months
now
turkish troops have of course been
massed at the border
with syria in light of the talks at the
kremlin today
is an assault by turkey on kurdish held
territory
now off the table
no it's not the turkish government keeps
emphasizing they're ready to launch
another military offensive uh they have
uh
reinforced troops and equipment along
the border
as well as inside syria some say that's
also present out on appealing to
nationalist voters ahead of the
local elections upcoming here in march
but of course any military operation is
very costly
and it will strongly depend on the
negotiations and agreements both
with washington and moscow yahan first
in istanbul
emily sherwin flores and moscow
following this talks about more on those
later today thanks for now
to both of you
you